اعمل فعله رئيس سابوه الاكاديكا واشار الى
ان بعض الدول الاوروبيه تقوم بقطع التجول
بالكهرباء على سكانها في الفترات المحدده
في
الاشهر الاخيره بسبب الازمه الغاز مع
روسيا لان اوروبا تريد الخروج من الهيمنه
يعني الغاز الروسي على اوروبا وروسيا تزوج
تقريبا
احتمال تزويد اوروبا بالكهرباء لان حتى
الدول كما قال الرئيس
مثل ما هو الحال الان مع الجزائر واسبانيا
وايطاليا لانها يمكن ان تتزوج مباشره
بالكهرباء عن طريق يعني كهرباء يمر تحت
البحر ينبت شمال شرق الجزائر منطقه الباب
الجنوب ايطاليا والجزائر حوالي 24000
ميجاوات في الوقت الحالي يعني فائض من
الكهرباء وهي تصدر كذلك الكهرباء لبعض دول
الجوار مثل همم يعني تونس ليبيا وتنوي رفع
انتاج الغاز الطبيعي لان الانتاج الكهرباء
في الجزائر تقريبا اكثر من 90% همم من
الغاز الطبيعي تنوي رفع الانتاج لرفع
الانتاج الكهرباء كذلك هو تعزيز الامن
الطاقه والاوروبي لان الشركاء الاوروبيين
تتحدث كثيرا ان على ان الجزائر يعني شريك
مضمون بالنسبه لتزوج بالقناه الطبيعيه
وحتى بالكهرباء المستقبل
لا من قبل رئيس تركيا ولا الملكه الاردني
الى الرئيس تبول في مقابله صحفيه عن
احتمال يكون الملك الملك الاردن قد زار
الجزائر مؤخرا قد قامت بدا مساعد
الوساطه بين الجزائر
والمغرب وليفربول قال ان الزياره عبد الله
الثاني لا علاقه
فسيكون هو الاول الذي سيعلم الشعب
الجزائري بالمعلومه ولا يخفي اي شيء وكان
كذلك المشادر اعلاميه تركيه تحدثت الرئيس
اردوغان بين الجزائر والمغرب حول هذه
الازمه الجزائر قطعت علاقتها دبلوماسيه مع
المغرب منذ اكثر من سنه في شهر اغسطس 2021
وسابقى الرئيس
ان الجزائر لا تقبل
مع المغرب بحكمه بمقال ان المغرب قام
بافعائيه يعني همم جعلت الجزائر
فرصه للاذاعه المتكرر الدوليه من الجزائر
العاصمه فيصل مطاوي شكرا جزيلا لك